c'est moi qui donne une chance de
combattre
tu va l'apprendre je fais la part
de voix basse et ton fils ton père
acclament ces
écoutes je sais que tu ne connais pas on
est des étrangers la barre le train mais
en tout cas tout ce que je sais c'est
que je suis tout ce que tu as alors ma
quand tu vas faire quoi
je suppose que tu étais jack e-justice
je le suis toujours on va voir ça
content de revoir
a grandi avec tes blessures a survécu
grâce à ta rage et c'est cette rage qui
t'a conduit jusqu'à la cache un combat
pour le titre
tu fait une apparition s'est dit mais
j'avais moi aussi quand j'étais petit
toit et m'arrive encore
[Musique]
je très bien